MIKI KONNO: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for having us.
I am Miki Konno.
This is Bethany Fong.
As you all know, Google takes
the user very seriously.
An essential part of
that is gather and
utilize user feedback.
And what we're going to talk
about today is how we do it.
I've been a UX researcher for
the last 12 years and have a
background in human factors and
organizational psychology.
Prior to Google, I worked at
Sony, HP, and Microsoft.
And I'm currently as a part of
Android UX team, focusing on
Android At Home project.
Although the majority of my work
is around end consumer
user, I've been proactively
involved in
Agile developer community.
And I am very happy
to be here.
BETHANY FONG: I'm Bethany Fong,
and I've been a designer
for Android for about
two years now.
And my background is in
engineering and product design
through Stanford's
design program.
And I'm very excited to be here
today to help you learn
how to do research, because
it's one of my
favorite parts of my job.
I love talking to real users
and seeing the unexpected
things they do.
And I love putting those
observations into design
improvements and ultimately
into code.
So today, in 40 minutes, we're
going to give you an overview
of UX research from an Agile
developer's perspective.
And we'll walk through four
case studies of different
testing methods that we use
in Android every day.
By the end of the talk, you'll
be ready to start running
tests on your own products.
So let's start with that
overview of UX research from a
developer's perspective.
So why should developers
care about UX testing?
Well, Dr. Claire-Marie Karat
from IBM has performed quite a
bit of research on return
on usability investment.
And she found that as
a rule of thumb--
for every dollar spent solving
a problem in design, you save
$10 in development, and you
save $100 in post-release
maintenance.
As developers, that should catch
your interest because
that's your time and
effort being
saved due to UX research.
And this is why we're
doing this talk.
We value efficiency and
robust products.
And we know that you
guys do, too.
So what kind of usability
improvements are you going to
invest that $1 into?
When you start looking into
it, you might encounter a
process like this--
the long, slow Japanese
tea ceremony.
It's complicated and requires
patience for everybody, and it
takes almost two hours to make
just one cup of tea.
But it's worth it in the end.
It's just not compatible with
the need for speed.
And here's the equivalent
process in the research world.
This is a traditional UX study
schedule laid out end to end.
And I do want to point out that
this is not how Android
runs design research today.
This process takes between five
to six weeks to run its
full course, starting from the
initial participant screener
creating the study, setting it
up, running it, and then
analyzing the results.
And when you overlay a typical
two-week software development
cycle over it, starting from the
task selection and ending
with a nice shippable increment,
you see that these
aren't compatible.
For the same user task, you can
start the research in the
software development at the
same week, where you'll be
done with the development
way before you even
start talking to users.
And you'll actually have a few
increments done by the end of
the testing phase.
So here are some of the needs
that we hear from developers
when they encounter a
timeline like that.
We hear, can we get
user feedback
before we start coding?
We need feedback on these
brainstorm ideas now.
Can't you get to the data
analysis any quicker?
And there's no time to
test every user story
that we want to build.
So maybe what we're looking for
is something more like the
espresso shop for the UX
research world and less like
Japanese tea.
Espresso is still a lovely
caffeinated beverage.
But it's a lot quicker to make
and it packs a punch.
OK, so let's look at the
landscape of how researchers
measure users.
and see which area is
"espresso-able." Here is UX
research laid out on a
two-by-two matrix.
This axis from top to bottom
is qualitative to
quantitative.
This axis from left to right
runs from people's goals and
attitudes to people's
behavior.
And you probably recognize a lot
of the different methods
laid out on this grid or have
participated in one of these
studies yourself.
This upper right quadrant, the
area pertaining to insights
into what people do, is the one
that works well for fast
turnaround and quick feedback.
And it's the most tactical.
All the other quadrants
are more strategic,
though equally important.
They do take more prep
time and more time
to analyze the results.
This upper left quadrant is--
you address this before you
start building anything.
It's more formative, and it
helps with concept creation.
This lower left, it's more
about market research.
It's more about existing habits
and behaviors, and you
have to gather a lot of
people to get results.
This lower right, we're getting
closer to Agile, but
it takes a lot of preparation
and analysis.
And although AB testing can be
fast, you don't get insights
into why people do
what they do.
So we're going to focus on the
most tactical methods from
this graph and insights
into what people do.
So we're going to give you
four examples of those
tactical methods that
we run in Android.
Let's start with the heuristic
evaluation.
Heuristic evaluation is, in
one word, measurement.
It helps you gain insight into
your products' performance
against typical behavior.
You're measuring against that
upper right quadrant.
It's a review of your product
against a set of usability
principles, such as the user
should know what's happening
in the system at all times.
Or there should be
no extraneous
information on the screen.
Think about your own
area of expertise.
How would you look at your
product from that
single point of view?
Maybe you're a security expert,
or you're the person
in charge of Help tools, or
you developed the design
principles for your team.
How could you measure an
existing product against your
own key principles?
If you need some ideas, there
are many lists of usability
heuristics online.
Just start with Wikipedia.
And if you were here for Helen
and Rachel's talk right before
this, that's another great
list that you could use.
So here's the process for
heuristic evaluation.
And I'm going to be using an
example from Android to
illustrate this.
A few months ago, another
company released a tablet, and
our leadership wanted to know
how long those set of
processes took.
This is a great question to
evaluate using a heuristic
method because it was a
quantitative question.
Great questions can be how
long does this take?
Or how many times might a user
need to navigate away?
Or something a little less
quantitative, but still
measurable, like how well does
this flow and adhere to
principle x.?
So we set up some speed-based
usability heuristics--
number of screens, number of
clicks, number of times to
enter text, minutes of loading
time, confusing language that
would slow somebody down.
Then we set up a room and time
to meet up with our key
stakeholders--
our researcher, our project
manager, and
our set up flow designer.
We then ran through the set-up
process together at a measured
pace, keeping track of time, but
also taking detailed notes
on each step of the process and
how well all the elements
on the screen helped us, the
user, get through setup as
quickly as possible.
I can't tell you in too much
detail what we found.
But we were pleased to
see that it was a
standard set-up process.
And it also used some industry
standard design niceties, like
using loading time to
educate the user on
how to use the tablet.
So we wrote a quick summary
report with what was good and
bad and how long
the setup took.
It actually took much longer
than we expected, about 10
minutes longer.
So what next?
So normally action items, when
you're running against your
own products, are usability
action items, like we have to
move this button, or we have
to change this wording.
But action items from running
a heuristic evaluation as a
competitive analysis usually
have to do with keeping up
with industry baselines.
And this helps with scheduling
our own work and saving our
respective teams and our
developers from churn.
So to recap what makes a
heuristic evaluation unique is
that it gives you evidence of
adherence to principles.
It requires one researcher, no
users, and no lab, so it's
pretty cheap and easy
to conduct.
Some things to keep in mind as
you're considering it is that
it doesn't put a real user
in front of you.
So even though it provides great
baseline knowledge, it
won't through you those
real-world curve balls.
And it'll always be subjective
based on which expert is
running it.
But it's a great place to get
basic understanding of your
own product and of your
competitors' products.
MIKI KONNO: Next I'm going to
talk about the RITE study--
Rapid Iterative Testing
and Evaluation
method, aka RITE method.
Some of you might be familiar
with this terminology.
This method was originally
created by a UX researcher in
game studio at Microsoft.
This is an iterative type of
usability method and commonly
used for the continuous design
iteration on prototypes.
Here's a common process
for the RITE study.
Starting with the research
question from the team, such
as well, I really need to get
quick feedback on this, an UX
researcher maybe put together
a brief script
and conduct a study.
I mean, this portion is very
similar to traditional
usability studies.
It's different because the
interface changes of the
prototype will be immediately
available after each user.
Therefore, this cycle
repeats itself.
Let's say you have five users
coming to the study for a
one-hour session each.
So you will start with the one
hour between each session, for
example, 9:00 AM and 11:00
AM, between one hour as
illustrated.
In this case, changes to the
interface are made immediately
after the first user.
Then interface is tested
with the second user.
This cycle continues until the
very last 5:00 PM user.
This method is frequently used
for small design changes, in
UI tweaks, or perhaps a
design explanation.
And it's great to use for the
prototype and great way to
make design improvements
in small increments.
It's preferred to have a
dedicated UX researcher to
require to facilitate, and a
dedicated designer or even a
developer is needed to
iterate the design.
It could be run in one day, as
illustrated, or you can spread
out to two days.
So here is the two-day
RITE method example.
For two-day RITE method, the
first design iteration can be
made after all three users
perform on the first day and
test of the new design with
three users on the second day.
And then you make additional
design changes after all users
are finished.
Let me give you some example
from a Nexus
7 Quick Start guide.
I don't know if you're familiar
with this, but to use
Nexus 7 with mobile network
data, you must first insert
and activate micro-SIM card.
So when one of the tech writers
approached me asking,
well, Miki, I don't know if this
graphic is going to work.
Because I really have a concern
around if the user
will understand how to remove
the SIM and orientation of the
SIM card itself.
So we basically decided to
run a two-day RITE study.
On the first day, we found
several issues with the very
first user.
So the user understood the
orientation of the SIM card,
but they still could not locate
the exact location of
the SIM card cart to using
a pin to take it out.
So the user had some
difficulty with it.
And when the second user did the
same thing, we felt like
we needed to change the
design quickly.
While I'm conducting the third
user, the designer put
together a new design
by next day.
So the second day, we used the
new design to test it with
three users.
This time, it worked really,
really well, much better than
we expected.
But again, any usability
study, there's
new stuff comes up.
At last, we made more design
changes after the whole study
is completed and shared the
result with the key
stakeholders.
Initially, they told me we have
only two weeks to finish
the design.
By that time, we thought, no,
it's not going to be possible.
But by the time we're done, we
feel like, wow, we really
still made it work.
So in summary, the RITE study
focuses on changes in the
design in an iterative manner.
It requires one researcher, or
one designer, or perhaps
developer, and five
to six users.
This type of study requires
a usability lab
or conference room.
And it takes a day or
two to conduct.
There are many pros of using
this type of method.
It's agile and using
real users.
And it's collaborative because
the team has to agree on each
design solution within
allocated time.
Remember, you have
only one hour to
come up with the solutions.
Visual and very focused, because
design changes are
instantly visible, and the team
is able to focus on a
very focused design issue,
one at a time.
BETHANY FONG: So our next method
is the Cafe study,
which is a very popular study
method at Google.
And as you can tell from the
picture, you get to talk to
real people in a Cafe study.
It's a quick way to get real
user feedback without needing
a lab or pre-recruited
participants.
You use your device, running a
prototype, in a cafe, and you
politely ask people if they
could give you their feedback
on your product.
And because you're asking real
people with busy lives, you
really have just a few minutes
for one or two
scenarios to test.
Like how would you share this
picture with your friend?
Or do you know where to go
after setup is done?
So a Cafe study is useful to get
fresh user eyes on small
and isolated usability issues.
And here's how we've used the
Cafe study method at Android.
As you might know, we created
the ability to put widgets on
the lock screen with
Jelly Bean 4.2.
And when we were prototyping
this, we experimented with
different visual and animated
ways of hinting that you could
put a widget on the
lock screen.
And one of them was putting bite
hints on the side of the
screen, showing that you can
swipe up or to the side to
access your widgets.
And this animation protruded
a little bit
into the Unlock area.
So we wanted to make sure that
people could still unlock
their phones without activating
the widgets.
And so this was a really good
Cafe study question because it
was a very bounded use case.
Can a user unlock their
device successfully?
So we then got set up with a
very quick script of a few
questions and several phones
running the widget prototype
with a few different lock
screen patterns.
A researcher and a note taker
then went to our Google cafes
to find some willing
participants.
And Google cafes, are great for
us, because Googlers are
usually very excited to help.
They have a lot of opinions,
and they are familiar with
usability studies.
And if you're part of a large
company, you will probably
find equally excited
participants among your employees.
And if you don't have large
herds of hungry coworkers to
access, there's always
the public.
You can go to a real cafe, or
a farmers' market, or a
shopping mall and ask
people there.
So over a couple of hours, we
ended up talking to 21 people
with a total of about 90 lock
screen attempts among them.
And it was conclusive.
No one accidentally triggered
the widgets when they unlocked
the phone, which is awesome.
It's very rare you
get that kind of
really conclusive evidence.
So we had found a hinting
mechanism that didn't activate
the wrong thing.
However, a different problem
arose, which is very few
people actually noticed and
asked what the white hinting
was for the widgets.
So then we went back to
the prototyping team.
We were able to tell them that
taking up home screen space
was fine functionally.
But we needed to keep working
on discoverability
for the next test.
And that's actually what
we did for our
next usability test.
So what makes Cafe study a
unique method is that it's a
quick way to assess those
wishy-washy design changes
that no one on your
team really knows
how to decide about.
But just put it in front of a
real user, and they will tell
you very quickly which one
you should go with.
And it's easy to put together
since you don't need a lab.
And the report is quick to write
because it's basically
yes or no and common reasons
why or why not.
Remember that you should just
test limited feature areas.
And because you're getting
a random sample of the
population, you don't know about
the user's background
with your product or with
similar products.
So you're really just testing
their behavior.
MIKI KONNO: So next we're
going to talk
about the Pulse study.
The reason why we call it Pulse
study is because the
method is to assess the current
health of the product.
And it's also structured
in the way that you can
constantly monitor the health
of the product.
The Pulse study uses continuous
user feedback along
with a sprint cadence.
Therefore, it takes only one
week from start to finish.
It meets sprint team's urgent
needs, works well with user
stories, or small features.
It's flexible to test any type
of research questions,
requires minimal advance
planning, and has immediate
product impact.
Here's what the process
looks like.
During the Monday scrum, we
decide what to test on the
particular week as a team.
Once we know what we're
testing, we
decide who to recruit.
We are lucky to have a dedicated
recruiter at Google
because she understands the
exact target users.
On Tuesday and Wednesday, I
decide what research method we
use based on what we're testing
and start creating a
lightweight protocol
or script.
And then I walk through with the
team usually because they
need to prep the design
or prototypes.
By the time Thursday and Friday
comes, we expect the
six users are already recruited,
and they come to
the usability study.
Sometimes we divide it into
three users on Thursday and
three users Friday, so that we
can decide to use the two-day
RITE method, we can do that.
Usually we spend one hour
for each participant.
It's a good length because you
can really focus within the
one-hour time frame.
Key finding will be sent
out after each daily
briefing with the team.
And then we then brainstorm
solution for the issues,
filing the bug, adding new
user stories and so on.
In summary, the Pulse study
structure is fast and flexible.
It can be used with many
different types of research.
It requires one researcher, a
couple of observers, and five
to six users.
In this type of study, it's a
good to use a usability lab or
conference room and takes a
week from start to finish.
It works well with the sprint
planning, mockups and demos,
smaller and simpler features,
and perhaps quick UI fixes.
It complements full-scale
research that requires more
users and which are typically
long term, complex, and
strategic in nature.
Now I would like to go in little
more detail about how
to run the Pulse study.
The first step is to decide what
you are really testing.
Do you want to test some
sprint build, what's a
so-called [INAUDIBLE]
at Google.
Perhaps a UX designer may be
having some mockups or
prototypes to show
to the user.
Or perhaps a industrial
designer wants to get
out-of-the-box solutions.
Next you need to decide who
is your target user?
In Android, especially with a
brand new product, we often
use internal people.
But we also use external users
to get more general insights
into usage and knowledge around
the released product.
Having a target profile will be
really helpful because it's
coming up with more focused
research questions as well as
it helps you determine
the relevancy of the
results from the study.
So now who's doing what?
You need to assign the team
to different roles and
responsibilities.
Usually I'll be the moderator
because I'm a UX researcher.
But other team members
are either
observers or note takers.
At Google, research project
is a team project.
When I joined Google, Bethany
immediately helped me out with
setting up the lab, taking
notes, observing, and sharing
key insights.
I thought she was helping me
because she's just nice.
Or I'm new.
But it turns out it was
the norm at Google.
It's invaluable to get team's
feedback before, during, and
after the study.
By the time you finish the
study, everybody knows what
happened and what kind of
solution they may need for the
particular product.
Now you need to determine where
you should perform to
study at, a lab like this or
maybe a conference room.
This is the Android
At Home lab.
As you can see, this
looks like real
second story buildings.
Homes exist inside
of our building.
I must admit I'm very lucky
to have a lab like this.
Bethany and another researcher
created this lab just for the
Android At Home project.
Some people are surprised when
they come to the lab.
This home lab is nice because
it has an environment where
user feels completely
comfortable
and truly feel home.
There's a kitchen table.
There's a couch, TV.
And then there's also an office
and a bedroom you don't
see in the picture.
We can use this space for
multiple purposes, such as
one-on-one usability sessions,
group sessions, even for the
team brainstorming in
the home context.
This is a wonderful space to
get feedback on the mobile
devices because it's more
realistic than using office
setup, as typically usability
labs look like.
There are three cameras, and
we can control from the
observation room.
This is the observation
room upstairs.
It's hooked up with AV equipment
so that team can
observe the sessions upstairs.
And we can also communicate
through walkie talkies.
There are many couches, so a
number of people can sit down
and relax and watch or
observe the study.
And there are white boards so
that the observer can write
down some issues or perhaps
doing some design solutions.
A conference room is also
right next to it.
Therefore, the team can attend
a video conference without
leaving the lab.
Actually, you really don't need
an elaborate lab to gain
user insights.
All you need is a couple
conference rooms, and the
Google Hangout.
For example, there was one
time our lab lost power.
It was completely shut down.
So we had to scramble because
three more users were coming.
So we immediately booked two
conference rooms, one for
conducting study, another
one for observer.
And then we used a Google
Hangout to continue the
session, and it worked
really well.
So once you have everything set
up in place, you are ready
to execute the study.
I'm sure some of you
have never done a
usability study before.
But you don't have to
worry about that.
Your job is to let users
speak up and talk about
your product honestly.
You can follow simple guidelines
to get maximum
insight from users.
Make them feel comfortable
when they come in.
How's your day?
How was traffic?
Hey, thanks for helping us.
Let them know problems
are not their fault.
Make sure to say something
like, well,
we're not testing you.
Don't worry.
We're testing the product.
We need your honest feedback.
And listen and observe
carefully, and repeat and
clarify what the user said.
What did you mean by that?
Could you please clarify?
OK, you know the basics.
But you still need to be very
careful what not to do.
For example, don't brag about
your product even though you
really feel like it.
I know this is your
precious baby.
You want to advertise how
awesome is your product.
But that's opposite of the
product usability studies.
Don't say something like,
isn't it awesome?
This is a great product.
And do not insult a user, even
if you kind of feel like it.
[LAUGHTER]
MIKI KONNO: It's never good
to say, seriously, dude.
I can't believe you
didn't know that.
It's always not a good idea
to make a user undergo
unnecessary suffering, even
though it's kind of fun to
watch it, right?
[LAUGHTER]
MIKI KONNO: Such as that's
still wrong.
You have to keep trying.
You need to find that button.
For observers, it's nice
to use the check boxes.
You don't need to take long
notes because it's really
cumbersome.
And it's really difficult to
take notes and observing user
at the same time.
It's very fast to log.
All you have to do is, I have
the list out so that you have
just to do the check box.
It's easier for observers to
attend a session without
worried about, do I need to help
Miki to take long notes?
So check box always helps
with your observers.
So the next step is a debriefing
with the team.
At Google, this is a very
important part of the study
because you get a lot out of it,
such as scrubbing action
items, and finding the
bugs, and so on.
And this is genuine
cross-functional
collaboration.
Maybe Bethany can comment on
that from a designer's
perspective.
BETHANY FONG: Sure.
So I just want to emphasize that
getting your whole team
together to have a
cross-functional debrief is
really important.
Because when the researcher
is telling you about key
problems, you can start
brainstorming ideas right
there and addressing things
like technical feasibility
issues, product scope, new
interactions you want to
introduce, all in
the same place.
And so everybody leaves with
an action item, and the
problem gets solved right
away instead of
languishing in your email.
And it's not just about
problem solving, too.
As the researcher points out,
successful features from the
study is rewarding as a team
to see all the things that
worked well.
MIKI KONNO: So the last
step is communication.
By the time the study is
finished, teams should know
what happened exactly.
But the important part of
wrapping up the study is
creating a report for us.
Stakeholders need to know what
happened and what changes
should be made.
And often having a report is
very useful because you may
not remember what happened
six months from now.
Once debriefing is done, I often
send out a very brief
summary of the result by
email to the team.
But sometimes, I need to do the
presentation for a wider
audience, because to address
critical issues and highlight
some of the problems by showing
pictures and playing a
video clips from the lab.
Just communicating the result
does not really guarantee the
actual changes.
And my job is not completely
done yet at that point.
So I often create a UX hot list
as a reminder that I need
to follow up these issues
to make sure
they will get resolved.
Having an impact on the issues
is much more important than
just conducting studies.
BETHANY FONG: So I'm going
to wrap this up.
And we hear a few frequently
asked questions.
The first is, what if we don't
have a user researcher?
This is especially true for
small development groups.
Well, of course, it's
great to have a user
researcher on your team.
And you can always hire a
consultant for a short-term or
a long-term project.
And remember that there's
still those three other
quadrants that can be
researched, if you remember
that matrix from
the beginning.
And a trained professional
will be probably best to
handle those.
But in a pinch, your product
manager, UX designer, or a
savvy developer could
run studies.
I think now that you've heard
our presentation, you have the
basic pieces that you
need to start.
Another question that we hear
is, what if we don't have the
budget to recruit users?
It sounds very expensive.
Well, you can use your own
employees, like we talked
about in the Cafe study.
Just make sure that they
aren't the ones who are
working on your product.
Or you can ask your customers
through social media to
participate.
And small monetary rewards or
gift cards always help and
aren't that expensive.
MIKI KONNO: Lastly, how do
user studies complement
acceptance testing?
Acceptance testing is testing
against the featured
requirements in the
sprint backlogs.
But a usability study is
for user requirements.
For example, a feature
requirement might be A, B, and
C. So OK, after usability
study sessions, we find
everybody can do A, B, and C.
But it could be with lots of
difficulty, or dissatisfaction.
Then what are you going to do?
And maybe a user desired D
instead of A, B, and C. Then
that could be a new
feature, right?
That is why usability studies
complement and do not replace
acceptance testing.
BETHANY FONG: So we've laid out
research methods that take
from one to two hours
to conduct, all
the way to a week.
And these are a great start.
You don't need lab space or
recruitment time for the
heuristic study or
the cafe study.
And you don't need weeks of a
dedicated researcher for the
quick change of the RITE study
or the in-depth results of a
Pulse study.
It's really easy to get started
investing that dollar
of design improvement.
Your users' feedback
is invaluable.
And we hope that after today,
you feel empowered to start
testing right away and funneling
those crucial
insights right back into
your products.
Thank you so much for coming.
MIKI KONNO: Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]